let's talk about the movie industry yeah
yeah because there was something i
wanted to bring up actually in all of
this context and it's the response we
saw from the establishment in the left
over alec baldwin and the shooting
because i've i've i've
went you know gone off on the alec
baldwin thing many a time
based on everything i've already read
about what happened with alec baldwin
for those that aren't familiar he was on
a movie set he had a a live gun a single
action revolver
um i can't remember what ammo type it
was i don't think it was 45 i'm not sure
but uh
he shot and killed cinematographer
pointed the gun at her pulled the hammer
back
then they say the gun went off killed
her he said he didn't know that she got
shot for 45 minutes which is to imply
that while he was holding the gun and
pointing at her pulling the hammer back
and then it banged and went off in his
hand which for which she felt the recoil
when she collapsed to the ground dying
he simply walked away and didn't bother
ask what was going on he did not even
know
she must have just fainted he said
so in my opinion based on this story
they've tried blaming the armorer who
was on the set
uh at first you know we were like wow it
sounds like an accident once we got the
real details
i think it is
more likely that alec baldwin was
extremely angry he's a hothead
and he shot and killed this woman i
think he wasn't he was just in a fit of
rage
i don't know how you could you could
argue that this circuitous
all these events took place that
coincidentally landed a live bullet and
a gun where the seer was broken so the
gun went off
but uh
nick you actually worked with that
armorer
yeah when i saw that uh you know i was
reading about the alec baldwin thing
when it first broke and it said you know
the armor there it was her second movie
and i was like oh my gosh it's hannah it
means you know i had done the old way
with nicholas cage back in august and
she was the armor on that film and
you know i
she seemed competent to me she taught me
how to load an old winchester and you
know i mean she
she did a good job
as far as i can tell i didn't have any
problems with her but the the thing
about the alec baldwin thing that makes
absolutely no sense
is
number one how did a live round get in
there i mean
i've never been on a set where there was
a live round i mean i just never
happened
and
the other thing that occurred to me too
in reading the steps he was handed the
gun
by a first a.d
who said
it's a cold gun
that's not how you do it
the armorer brings the gun to you
shows you everything that's in the gun
if you're firing the gun it's you know
the armor will say you have two rounds
here
and then the blanks you pull the trigger
twice and then it's done there's no more
bullets in the gun so you know exactly
what's in the gun
at all times and even if the even if
they say cut they come and they take the
gun away from you for 30 seconds
when the armorer brings the gun back he
does the same thing he shows you every
single time
i don't know how in the world
you know that that happened with alec
baldwin with the first ad just handing
him a gun alec baldwin not looking in
the gun
and
and then pulling the trigger you worked
with this uh this hannah this armorer
yeah and when you worked with her she
showed you the gun
and explained to you the ammo that all
that stuff as you described yeah
well and and the other thing that i've
read about the alec baldwin shooting is
that hannah the armorer was not in the
room
because
sag has these coveted restrictions and
people have designations of a b or c and
if you're in the b group or the c group
you can't be indoors with people in the
a group
so
hannah was not allowed to be in that
church
when
the the he was using the gun then it
sounds like the production team is
liable of some sort of felonious
activity oh absolutely incompetence if
nothing else and the other thing too
that was a rehearsal
he was just
you know they weren't shooting the scene
every time i've never done a rehearsal
with a gun it's a rubber gun it's not
they don't even give you the real gun
until you're actually shooting the scene
where you have to see the real gun i've
heard that they were like had live
rounds and they were target practicing
between shoot days and takes and stuff i
don't know how to confirm that or deny
that but i've heard that i've heard that
too i mean that's very very uh that's
not that's not normal that's what
they're doing and i can also believe it
like out in the f in the west out in the
desert a bunch of them just kind of like
20 people making a movie on the fly kind
of like having fun drinking beer at
night yeah and a lot of it too was that
you know he he had had some crew
problems or whatever the crew was a lot
of the crew had quit because of the
conditions on the set there were
previous uh discharges you know
accidental discharges that they said the
set wasn't safe a lot of the crew had
quit and so he'd replace them with less
experienced people
so there's a big convergence of a whole
lot of incompetence that went in there
but to your point
i don't know how alive round gotten that
gun i mean and and for him to be if if
it's like you said if he was there he's
got that experience yeah and not just
that it isn't that there was simply one
live round in one gun one time you're
saying there were multiple discharges on
set that made crew feel unsafe yeah and
this is not live round discharges this
is just okay this is just blanks
but you know whenever a gun's going to
be fired you say fire in the hole
everybody knows because you got to get
the ear protection out whatever you know
there were just a couple of times when
the gun went off and everybody went what
the hell what are you doing you know i
was the one saying i've heard that they
were doing target practice with live
rounds on set and they were a mix of
live rounds and dummy rounds and they i
heard that too i've been reading about
it i don't know how to confirm or deny
it but i mean come on there was a live
round on set so sometimes they will
usually it's a different day but if
you're shooting
like if you're shooting a lot in a movie
they will take you to a range and let
you feel what the recoil is on a real
gun so that when you're acting and
you're shooting blanks you can act like
you know you're you're actually firing
the real thing so that happens but
that's usually like if that happens it's
on a different day and it's it it
totally separate from
i mean if they're just walking around
back and you know
some cans or something that's that's not
acceptable the response we end up seeing
strangely is uh tribal people defending
alec baldwin in the establishment left
people criticizing him in the
anti-establishment right and it
seemingly has nothing to do with
politics i mean alec baldwin is you know
democrat you know activists and all that
stuff maybe that's a big reason but what
happened with alec baldwin is not
political
yet here we are well the i think the
only thing people see as political is
the aftermath of that him getting away
with it and he's getting away with it
because he's part of the
left-wing establishment you know that
they they don't want to go after him
because just like you were saying
earlier the people in uh dc are going to
be put in for in front of democrat
jurors who will convict them yeah alec
baldwin will never see a day you think
that people are like
i i know he did it and i know he's
responsible but i love his work so much
that i don't want to put him in jail
because i want to see another alec
baldwin movie
he's not that great he's not dead i
think it's a tribal but he has zealous
fans
i'll follow him to hell and back but
what percentage of the population could
that be like point zero zero zero you
know you saw eighty thousand people or
something if you saw team america world
police you know alec baldwin is the
greatest actor in the world 100
i mean i like his work backdraft yeah
yeah
pretty good too beetlejuice yeah great
movie fantastic i've liked him in
certain things yeah oh yeah his talent
is undeniable but also you know that's
not what this is about
it should never be about no
it took someone's life in my case
of course yeah it's all very tough
you're extremely talented so well one
question i'd like to ask nick i'm
curious as you were working on this
documentary what was the most
interesting thing you discovered
well when we went into it we the
original title of the movie was the
trouble with free speech because i saw
this as like the government suppressing
free speech and trying to keep these
people from you know deter these people
from ever coming to washington and and
making their voices heard again but what
what we wound up discovering is that by
talking to these people
who had been visited by the fbi and the
way they were being treated and the that
was the most shocking thing it's just
like every story in this movie you just
can't believe that this is america
they are coming to these people's houses
these are people that have never been
arrested for anything before in their
lives
and they're 6 am
swat teams 20 rifles red dots on their
chest come out with your hands up
uh handcuffing their wives and daughters
and breaking down doors and i mean it's
real
terrorist kind of gestapo like tactics
and
as these stories started to pile up i
was just like okay this is
this is the story we have to tell this
is this is this is what this movie's
about it's about how these people are
being treated and why are they being
treated that way
and so that you know to to realize that
your government is intentionally
terrorizing
innocent people
only one of the only one of the people
that we interview ever went in the
building and those are the two twin 74
year old grandmothers everybody else is
outside never went inside so we we
started talking about how you had worked
with the armorer on on uh from the um
the alec baldwin movie hannah
what's her name i can't remember
gutierrez yeah so so we mentioned you
you've worked with her you've been in tv
shows and movies
how has it been trying to continue that
career after making a documentary like
this and voting for trump and thing you
know have they have i can't imagine
they're very happy with you well no but
you know i have i've worked in the
business long enough that i have friends
who know who i am and hire me anyway you
know and
you know sometimes it's not
you know i don't know i i still continue
to get work here and there it's not as
much as it used to be that may be
because i'm old or or it may be because
i'm a
right-wing
radical republican insurrectionist you
know
i don't know but i you know like i say i
have relationships that
uh you know sustained me to this day and
and i'm also
at this point in my life i'm really much
more interested in
pursuing movies that i want to make that
i want to have some control over and i'm
not so much interested in just like
trying to get a job in somebody else's
left-wing garbage what's uh what are you
what are you working on now or is there
something you've worked on recently
um well uh
terror on the prairie is a movie that's
coming out with the gina carano that'll
come out june 10th that's the daily wire
movie um
and uh
but that's already done i'm i'm trying
to put together some uh movies that uh
a couple of narrative features that i
wrote with a partner blake ellis uh
one called where i'm bound which is
about gospel quartet music in the 60s
that's very
sexy subject and um and i'm also there's
another documentary i want to make about
the
1972 olympic men's basketball team that
got screwed by the russians oh wow and
11 of those guys are still alive this is
the 50th anniversary this year of of
that game and uh
all those guys have refused the silver
medal to this day and the one guy that
passed away put it in his will that no
one in his family can ever
never take that silver medal because
they were just blatantly cheated out of
the gold medal interesting what's the
story there
they basically was a close game
and it's interesting because uh
you know a lot of the best players in
america didn't play that year like bill
walton wouldn't play he had just come
out of ucla and this is before they let
professional players play
so it was not
i mean it was a good team but it wasn't
like the best of the best right
and so it's very close game and they
replayed the last three seconds of the
game three times until the russians won
what
they
america was up by one point doug collins
hit two free throws with three seconds
left and russia was taking the ball out
of bounds under
america's basket they had to go to
length of the court
they played the three seconds the first
time and threw the ball out of bounds
and time ran out and
the referee said oh no he called timeout
before
before the ball was thrown in and
they're like no no he did nobody called
timeout and then they did it again they
they replayed that three seconds again
some other problem and they had like
well not to tell the whole story but
there were five judges that let them
replay the three seconds a third time
and on the third time they threw the
ball the link that the court the russian
center pushed the american out of bounds
caught the ball and put it in and they
won by one point was it a soviet uh
judge judges all five of them
it was it well it was no it was two
pro-soviet judges and two
pro-america judges and the fifth judge
was supposed to be this judge from egypt
who was pro he was pro-western but when
the israeli athletes were murdered nine
days before this game
egypt pulled all their athletes
out of the olympics and that judge was
not there and they put in another judge
who was a russian well this is a good
story
it's a great story it really is it's a
great story because it's it's
geopolitics it's the cold war it's you
know it's all that stuff and all and
also with the
the killing of the israeli athletes at
that olympics it's sort of that's kind
of why this story got forgotten because
it wasn't as important as that you know
what's a budget for a movie like that
well it's it i see it as a four four
hour documentary yeah i could probably
make it about
million one point five i could probably
how do you how does a how does a person
come across money like that to make a
movie
well you gotta
talk you gotta convince uh investors
that you can make some money with it you
know and and
you know a lot of times with a movie
like this you pitch it to espn or you
pitch it to netflix that's the easiest
way
but to make it independently you gotta
you gotta and that's what we've been
trying to do because
netflix won't talk to me
are you taking donations to produce the
movie
um
we're not taking open donations i mean
you know we we're not
that's complicated process
uh
so we're trying to find you know
you spin up like a corporation that like
owns the movie and then that's
yeah like a llc yeah i just recently
found out that's kind of how hollywood
works is when they make a movie they
make a corporation that owns the movie
and then they can give like people
percentages of that corporation right
that work on that movie and every movie
kind of has to have its own company
right
so yeah but it's you know i have some
people interested and
you know that's that's that's something
that i would really like to do soon have
you done anything with crypto
see i'm old i don't even know what
crypto is
who knows i'm talking about crypto i go
i know
oh actually crypto is our tracking
mechanism i don't know yeah it's the
evolution of digital currency i really i
have no i literally when you guys were
talking about crypto before i was like
okay i have nothing to add i don't know
i don't even know what it is it's like
an immutable ledger is the difference
between that in banking is that there's
an online ledger that can't supposedly
can't be tampered with so you can
everything's there for view right
decentralized digital banking right and
stores of value
different cryptocurrencies have
different characteristics so they're
easier harder to move and then sometimes
you get into it where certain types of
crypto can do things like on a certain
network you can give someone one and
it'll give you a thousand views on the
network or so that they're called smart
contracts that they can build in so that
they actually do things instead of just
being like bland currency well like how
do you buy stuff with it
um give it to somebody you got to sell
it usually for dollars on coinbase or
something like that or you can trade it
to someone that wants to take it for
currency as simple as this
i uh i would like those glasses sir i'll
give you a rock for it okay so if i've
got if i've got an account with five
crypto in it i could be like hey that
jacket's mighty fine i'll give you a
crypto for it you know just generic i'll
say ethereum and then you'll be like
okay and then i just text it to you you
know just and then how do i but like can
i take that to the 7-eleven and buy gas
with it no you move it over to your
wallet on this website called
coinbase.com or something like that
where and then they'll buy your ethereum
and give you dollars and it'll direct
deposit it into your bank account
without a day or something soon
probably in the next you know five ten
years you will be able to go to 7-eleven
and use crypto costa rica just named
bitcoin their national currency
el salvador el salvador el salvador
really yeah so they're they're a crypto
economy now and it's been really great
for their caught for their standard of
living
because bitcoin is uh uh there's only so
many
so it's uh
you can't you can't print more
only it's mined through a complicated
process and there's only so many that
can exist which means after a long
enough period of time the value can only
go up because the amount of bitcoin can
only go down
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast if you
want to watch live you can check out
this channel monday through friday at
8pm now don't forget to smash that like
button subscribe to this channel and if
you want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time
you